so good afternoon everyone I'm Kim go
Cruz and it is my privilege to welcome
you here today as we honor our
veterans now before we begin I would
like to thank the Yale Police Department
color guard for presenting the colors
and express our deep gratitude to the
Quinnipiac people for this land on which
we
stand it is my pleasure to warmly
welcome the students faculty staff and
alumni who are with us today who have
served and who are preparing to serve
our country we are grateful for the
freedoms and privileges that your
sacrifices have made
possible each member of our veterans
community contributes to the vibrant
culture of our
University during our ceremony you will
hear from a veteran leader and a current
student and we will honor a former staff
person who has supported and advocated
for Yale
veterans our speakers and our Honore
represent commitment to honor and
Country to our veterans and to those who
care for them and support them so we
will start and I was now my pleasure to
introduce president Peter
[Applause]
salv thank you vice president Cruz
appreciate that introduction thank you
all for being here and it gives me great
pleasure to see so many members of the
Yale Community gathered for our
commemoration of Veterans Day it's a
privilege especially to extend a warm
welcome to current and former servicemen
and service women who are here with us
today uh why don't we recognize all
those in the service uh today
so for over three centuries yel students
faculty staff and alumni have answered
dutifully and with distinction the call
to
serve the University's proud tradition
of service began with the Revolutionary
War and it includes nearly 30,000 yis
who served in the first and second world
wars and in Korea and in
Vietnam and now the tradition
continues it continues through those who
are enlisted in the reserve Officers
Training Corps on campus as well as the
many veterans in our community and
ceremonies like this one remind us of
the tremendous sacrifices our veterans
have made to keep the peace in a world
that has become a more dangerous
place in the words of former Secretary
of State and Yale honorary degree
recipient the late meline Albright while
democracy in the long run is the most
stable form of government it is in the
short run among the most
fragile the price of Liberty as noted by
the eminent Wendell Phillips and many
others is internal
vigilance around us threats to democracy
stoked increasingly by disinformation
and the division that it SWS demand our
utmost
vigilance standing watch are those who
sit before
us every veteran here today understands
that the essential values in which we
believe so
deeply require
sacrifice I'm thinking of how the
veterans assembled here this afternoon
exemplify our highest ideals I'm
reminded of what Yale looks for and more
particularly whom it looks for several
decades ago University president Kingman
Brewster memorably distilled the yell
admissions process as this is he his
words a combination of looking for those
with a zest to stretch the limits of
their talents and those with an
outstanding public
motivation we have to make the hunchy
Choice he
said as to whether or not the candidate
for admission is likely to be a leader
in whatever they end up
doing so let there be no doubt that with
each of our Yale veterans that with each
of you who have set out to improve the
world for this and future
Generations we got it right Yale made
the right decision you have rewarded our
hunch and most importantly you have
represented the best of humanity with
your
heroism and so for this you have our
deepest gratitude you have our deepest
admiration for bringing great honor to
this University of course it yell we are
ever aware of Our obligation to pair our
words in support of veterans with action
that provides it yel I'm proud to say is
routinely recognized among the best
colleges in the nation for veterans in
part due to our commitment to ensuring
that a yal education is Affordable for
everyone such as through our
participation in the yellow ribbon
program just as an example we strive
also to honor and support our servicemen
and women through the Yale veterans
Network a campus group for students
faculty and staff and the Yale veterans
association for our alumni and beyond
our campus meanwhile the L law school is
helping to rid the veterans benefit
system of racial disparities we have
many from the law school here today by
supporting our veterans we affirm our
unending appreciation to them for
strengthening our society indeed
sustaining our society through their
service and sacrifice so I want to
close by shifting from Yale's efforts to
yours
the ultimate test of a person's
conscience said Senator Gaylord Nelson
may be their willingness to sacrifice
something today for future
Generations whose words of thanks will
not be
heard so today let our words of thanks
ring out loudly to reach those veterans
in our community who have passed this
test and the service members on campus
who have enlisted to join them The Valor
of Yale's veterans is a source of
tremendous Pride to this
University and I want to thank you all
once more for being here today and for
helping us to honor them and you thank
you very
[Applause]
[Music]
much
n
the
[Music]
H God order
close
C sorry
sir good afternoon I V leware co-chair
of the Yale veterans Network and I here
to recite the invocation if those of you
who could stand please stand at this
time grand architect of the universe
called by many names in many languages
by many voices today we ask that your
guiding hands hold us and all sisters
and brothers in military service near we
are grateful for all who now serve all
who have served and all for those who in
the words of President Abraham Lincoln
gave the last full measure of devotion
in service of their country we are
joined in humility gratitude and our own
measure of devotion knowing that as we
seek to understand an increasingly
complex world we are sheltered by the
Vigilant service of citizens to our
Republic we ask special regard for those
who have served but who have not yet
been found and returned home and for
those who have returned but who have yet
to find themselves at home we honor our
military and ask that whatever is
required of them be informed by your
Infinite Wisdom the light and the truth
as they honorably and loyally seek to
create a peaceful and secure future for
us all
you may be
seated good afternoon everyone uh first
I'd like to recognize and thank
president salv secretary G Cruz provos
stroble Dean Pericles Lewis chapl saltio
and the Veterans Day committee
I'd like to personally thank Dean
reod miss Patricia we Mr Jack beer head
heider Dean Chan Hoke and all of my fall
term professors because they will
inevitably influence my GPA in a few
weeks most importantly I'd like to thank
the veterans reservists National
Guardsmen active duty service members
civil service members firefighters law
enforcement personnel and their families
who will willly sacrifice and endure
more than most will ever know for being
in attendance to everyone else thank you
for being here and supporting this
event it's truly an honor to have been
selected and given the responsibility to
provide my remarks here today although I
will describe what Veterans Day means to
me I want to emphasize that I do not
intend to have the last word on the
meeting of Veterans Day or how we should
observe or honor it today my only goals
are to underscore the importance of
unity in our society
thank those that have had and will
continue to have a profound impact on my
life and honor the sacrifices of
veterans and Uniform service
members to me Veterans Day is not meant
to be exclusive it is not a day for
civilians to thank veterans and Uniform
service members and it is certainly not
a day for veterans and service members
to rest on their Laurels bask in
America's gratitude and become
complacent to me Veterans Day is
inclusive to all Americans and it is
meant to remind us of the importance of
unity it is a day for all Americans to
acknowledge the fact that America's
Freedom was achieved and is maintained
through the selfless sacrifices that
have transcended and continue to
transcend every group and every class of
American
society each year Veterans Day provides
an opportunity for civilians to thank
those who have served for their
sacrifices but simultaneously it
provides veterans and service members
with a chance to thank the civilians
mentors friends and family members that
have supported and continue to support
them throughout their Journeys for those
of us who have served and are currently
serving this day should remind us to
lead by example keep striving for
greatness and live our lives in a way
that would make those we knew who paid
the ultimate sacrifice proud but perhaps
most importantly Veterans Day is meant
to remind us all that freedom is not
free it is realized through action and
it can only be maintained when as a
Americans we unify and collectively
support each other in our efforts to
improve our society and create a better
world before I get into my military
service and my path to becoming a
veteran at Yale I'd like to share a bit
about myself I grew up in southern
Minnesota in a town of less than 2,000
people with my mother father sister and
brother my siblings and I had a tough
upbringing in what I would consider to
be a broken home we had little money my
parents were addicted to opioids and
different forms of abuse or common
occurrences in my household I've often
been asked about the decisions and
actions that I undertook to persevere
through adversity in my childhood what
made me different than those who went
through similar struggles but ended up
in different places and what lessons
I've learned along the way in response
to those questions I always say two
things first when faced with adversity
leaders do what needs to be done
regardless of how unpleasant those
actions and decisions may be the second
and more important thing I say is that
there is no such thing as
self-made when I needed to get away or
have a place to stay for a night it was
the bori and Westfall families that
opened their homes and provided me with
the support I needed I was not different
I was not unique I did not persevere
through the adversity of my adolescence
on my own leaders in my community
rallied around me they gave me
encouragement during dark times and they
held me accountable when I needed it
most it took a village to build me up
and show show me Pathways to success and
I'm forever grateful for their support
and
Leadership my experiences in the
military were no different in 2010 I
joined the military to provide support
for my family and create a promising
future for myself but shortly after en
list enlisting I learned that personal
and professional success would not come
easy I spent the first two years of my
military service and training where I
struggled to build strong personal
connections failed far more than I
succeeded in my professional ende and
neglected to reach out and be there for
my family who I claimed to be
supporting it wasn't until I arrived at
my first unit at Fort Brag North
Carolina that I began to achieve more
consistent success and gain perspective
that I needed when I arrived at Fort
Brag I met two two individuals that
forever changed my life one who is here
today and one who is not the one who is
with us here today was second Lieutenant
Chris Brown now Major
Brown when I arrived at my unit I was
arrogant loud selfish I wasn't a good
friend I wasn't a good teammate and I
definitely wasn't a leader like the
others Chris had every reason to
distance himself from me but instead he
coached challenged and mentored me in
all areas of my life his methods were
often non-traditional but they were
effective from politely encouraging me
to put on a gas mask and body armor and
run a half marathon at lunch in 100°
heat to quizzing me on radio communic
procedures that were last relevant
during World War II he taught me a few
valuable lessons by providing me with a
half marathon for lunch he taught me
that you have to do what others W to
achieve what others don't by running
those half marathons with me he showed
me that as a leader you can never ask
somebody to do something that you
wouldn't do
yourself and by quizzing me on the
communications techniques of World War
II soldiers he taught me that you can
learn something from
everyone Chris taught me how to be a
friend teammate and leader but most
importantly he taught me what it means
to be a man thank you
Chris the second person I met at Fort
Bragg was Staff Sergeant Brandon Cen tol
Brandon and I had a lot of similarities
and he was one of the only people that I
talked openly with about my past and the
loss of my father after telling Brandon
about my reason for joining the military
and my commitment to my family he held
me accountable and encourage me to be
more involved with my mother and
siblings upon noticing my inability to
build strong personal connections and
friendships Brandon invited me to work
weekend Gatherings and made me a part of
his friend group and he advocated for me
as an asset to the unit and the broader
military family
community nevertheless Brandon and I's
friendship ended on August 25th 2012
when he passed away in a motorcycle
accident in Spring Lake North
Carolina Brandon served three tours in
Afghanistan once or receiving the Purple
Heart Brandon was and is known for the
profound impact that he had on the lives
of everyone he knew and today his
influence continues to positively affect
those that knew him and those that never
did Brandon's sister Kaylee and brother
cam are with us here
today and each year in do New Hampshire
their family organizes a memorial event
and provides a scholarship in Brandon's
name Brandon's impact in life and death
should remind us that the way we live
our lives and the impr we put on this
Earth are lasting they have meaning and
they could change someone else's life
thank you for being here today Kaye and
Cam I share these two stories with you
today because Chris and Brandon
exemplify the selflessness empathy and
Leadership that most veterans and
service members leverage to create
impact on a daily basis outside of
selfless sacrifice and defense of
freedom and democracy veterans provide
two two broad things to society
leadership and
perspective regardless of Branch
occupation or combat experience veterans
appreciate and embody transformational
leadership they give their subordinates
the space and responsibility to succeed
or fail but they're always around and
willing to build their people back up
veterans know that when you dare to be
great you either win or you learn they
know and believe this because their
lives depended on it as Leaders veterans
prioritize empathy and individualized
consideration and when times get tough
veterans never let others struggle on
their own struggle and suffering are
necessary for growth and throughout life
every person is subjected to both but
when these unpleasant conditions leave
one lost and without Direction veterans
are often uniquely positioned to provide
the perspective that most do not have
veterans understand that no matter what
you're going
through no matter how difficult and
troubling your situation may be there is
someone else who went through something
worse and they probably dealt with it
more gracefully than you are
currently these selfless individuals
have an intimate understanding of
hardship and when veterans integrate
into the civilian populace they benefit
the collective by eliminating defeatism
and creating hope living veterans
provide significant value to our society
but it is the Fallen veterans that
provide us with an example of what we
should aspire to be fallen veterans
remind us to be selfless and to
prioritize the mission and the people
but perhaps most importantly they remind
us that we could be far greater than we
currently
are today in 2023 our society is in need
of unity and one way to work toward
achieving that Unity is by Bridging the
military civilian divide in my opinion
places like Yale University offer the
perfect environment to work toward that
goal and unity can be realized through
interactions between Yale's traditional
students and the University's veteran
Community Yale's traditional students
challenge veterans in many ways and they
are critical in forcing veterans to
consider New Perspectives and embrace
innovative ways of
thinking that said it is not lost on me
that as I stand here today I am in the
presence of some of America's Heroes and
each day as I walk around this campus
I'm thankful that Yale's traditional
students have the opportunity to learn
from them Heroes like Chris hallow Jimmy
hatch Conor McAvoy Danny mccoslin will
Meyers and Steve Sheffer are some of the
greatest veterans and active duty
service members that our country has to
offer and they provide more experience
knowledge and expertise to Yale's
traditional students than I could put
into words however these men and the
many male and female veterans that I did
not mention offer much more they are
Sons daughters brothers sisters husbands
wives fathers and mothers and in my
opinion they can teach us a whole lot
about how to live a wholesome life and
be a good person to the r to the RC
Cadets and students aspiring to serve in
attendance I want to personally thank
you for your selflessness and
willingness to serve our country after
Yale you will have the option to do
whatever you want and with a Yale degree
you will be choosing one of the most
difficult but rewarding paths serving
the United States of America was the
greatest responsibility and opportunity
that I've ever been given and I hope
that in a few years you feel the same
way the world is filled with chaos and
uncertainty and we should all be
thankful that there are people like you
willing to answer our nation's call you
are you are all heroes in your own right
and I hope you know that thank you all
for your
[Applause]
time
[Music]
for
all right you may be
seated I'm still feeling that are you
yeah so the university recognizes
outstanding contributions to Yale
veterans with the annual Veterans Day
tribute award the recipient of the 2023
veterans tribute uh Day tribute award is
to John Jack
beer now the reality is most of us know
Jack so he really doesn't really need
introduction but I'm going to give him
one anyway one because we want to make
sure that he knows how we see him and
what he's meant to us and the second is
because we want a written record in our
archives of who he was and what he
meant Jack is a unit a United States Air
Force veteran retired Yale business
leader University Citizen and a longtime
Champion for veterans at Yale he is with
us today with his family welcome and we
are thrilled to publicly recognize his
contributions in
2016 Jack became the inaugural veterans
liaison at Yale his charge from provos
Ben poock whom I see in the audience was
to create an Implement a plan to support
University Affiliated military
veterans now the job was intended to be
part-time but those of you who are
familiar with Jack know that there was
nothing part-time about his dedication
he was the first central point of
contact for student faculty staff and
alumni military
veterans Jack became a champion of
veterans and a problem solver he
supported staff veterans through the
Innovative veterans count campaign and
created important connections with our
student veterans notably those in the
Eli Whitney program in yel college and
the veterans enrolled in the law school
and School of
Management at the time student veterans
felt underrepresented and un unheard and
Jack became their advocate he listened
and acted on their behalf building a
network of leaders and staff across the
university who who valued all
veterans this resulted in policy changes
advocacy and relationships that improve
the University's environment for
veterans veteran students and
staff as you all know some of our
military Affiliated students are
preparing to serve through Yale's Naval
and Air Force rltc programs many are
here with us today Jack has been an
unwavering supporter of rltc and
especially welcoming and helpful when
new commanding officers arrived on
campus
he has also worked extensively with the
Yale veterans Network which is our staff
veterans affinity group and with the
Yale veterans association our veteran
alumni once again creating positive
relationships between veterans across
the university to improve culture and
experiences as president Sal salv
mentioned two years ago US News and
World Report ranked Yale the number one
school in the country for veterans and
active duty service members
while this was a recognition of great
Collective effort across the
university the ranking was due in no
small part to the role that Jack played
in helping to create the environment in
which veterans active duty service
members and student participants in Roc
are valued and
respected Jack if you can come up on
behalf of our entire University and
especially our veterans I want to thank
you for all of you contributed to create
a strong community of
respect connection and belonging for our
veterans this is an award that's so well
deserved so I'm going to give you a
small token and maybe say
remarks one second let give this
token thank you thank
[Music]
you
president salave secretary golf Crews
officers of Yale US military veterans
and their families and other honored
guests happy Veterans Day thank you for
being here to acknowledge the service of
our veterans and their
families well you've already heard more
about me than you probably want to know
I'm going to tell you
more during my first attempt at College
I was a marginal student as I was unable
to balance my need for fun with academic
re realities I withdrew and while I like
to call it a tactical Retreat it was
actually an
escape I enlisted in the Air Force and
served from November 1965 to July of
1969 to put that in historical
perspective Neil Armstrong a Navy
veteran and Buzz Aldren an Air Force
veteran walked on the moon within weeks
of my return King and Kingman Brewster a
Navy veteran was the president of Yale
and to date the only veteran to have
served in that capacity however I'm told
we're getting another president soon
never
know uh after receiving my honorable
discharge I was told not to wear my
uniform home on the flight from Seattle
at that time many Americans blamed
Veterans for the war and while I know
now that it was misdirected anger I
didn't know it then it was painful and
it was embarrassing and I felt insulted
that my service had been disavowed and
cancelled I didn't discuss my military
experience for many years and could
never have imagined that I'd be standing
before you today at Yale honoring
veterans I've learned a great deal in
the ensuing years after the 9/11 attacks
on New York and Washington I was
concerned concerned with safety at Yale
and my first thought was to find the
veterans on campus because I knew they
could be called on to stand
watch and that they would understand and
respond and serve in 2001 we had no way
to do this today we are more connected
than ever with encouragement from
Relentless alumni from the late 1960s
you all know who you are and the support
from our administration led by the
daughter of a Navy
Admiral we've come a long way rooc units
celebrated a decade back on campus
there's a full-time University liaison
for veterans and Military Affairs and
teams from admissions the Dean's office
the registar financial aid and our
office of diversity inclusion and
accessibility have extended themselves
to make Yale the University of choice
for many veterans the warrior scholar
program was founded at Yale it supports
enlisted veterans who like me had little
awareness of their future potential
until their military service and while I
didn't have the warrior scholar program
available to me I did meet a lovely
nurse from New York who said Jack you're
a really good softball player but have
you ever thought of going back to
college I did go back for my degree and
I also married her and we will be
celebrating our 53rd anniversary on
November 29th thank you for everything
Barbara I'm fond of saying that veterans
are better by being at Yale that Yale is
better by having veterans studying here
and our country is made much stronger by
both the common Bond created by service
to others to our community and to our
country is strong and runs deep at Yale
and in the
military this bond is
intergenerational and self-perpetuating
Veterans and alumni willingly accept
responsibility to current students and
active
military this spring I was contacted by
a member of the class of
1968 wanting to know how he could
support our undergraduate
veterans interestingly enough he had
served in the Army a few miles from pleu
Airbase at the same same time I was
stationed there he traveled from the
Midwest to New Haven to meet me and two
of our veteran students after dinner he
sent a note which I
quote both of them are truly unique
individuals and quite extraordinary in
their own ways they make me proud to be
a vet who graduated from Yale that's
from a 1968 graduate in in the the
darkest part of the University's
relationship with the
military they make me proud as well the
intersection of Yale in the military has
incalculable potential to improve both
I'm proud of all that has been
accomplished but this being Yale I know
the best is yet to come personally I've
only expected three things from my
military service the respect of those
who served before
me the respect of those who served after
me and a flag on my coffin which in my
case will be the same one used to drape
my father-in-law's casket as he was a
World War II veteran of the army
airp I've receed so much more than that
from my service including GI Bill
support to complete my college education
and most importantly an understanding of
Duty and responsibility to myself and to
others today I thank you for your
support of our veterans that special 11%
of our population who pledged to defend
our constitution with their lives they
understand what it means to be part of
something larger than themselves and
they support those who followed in the
same path it's very difficult for me to
describe my emotions on days like this I
burst with pride in seeing the women and
the men in our Roc programs the Next
Generation preparing to protect and
defend us and my interactions with
undergraduate veterans and active
military studying here fill me with
optimism for America's
future their presence is a validation of
all veterans decisions to
serve in recent years I've been thanked
many times for my service to my country
while visiting friends in Wisconsin I
had a chance meeting with an Iowa farmer
who was a Vietnam veteran we talked
briefly and found that we were in
country at the same time when we parted
he said to me with tears in his eyes
welcome home
brother I feel at home and welcome at
Yale as everyone should be I thank you
for the opportunity to serve the veteran
Community here happy Veterans
[Music]
[Applause]
Day
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm
[Music]
n
he
[Music]
[Applause]
and
[Music]
Happ
so
[Music]
[Applause]
please stand as you are willing and
able may we go forth from this place of
profound memory and deep meaning with
grateful hearts and
souls grateful for the sacrifice and of
our veterans and their families let us
never forget all they have done to
bravely protect freedom and human
rights from the moment our veterans make
the commitment to serve they were
committing to a life that would forever
be
changed may we be mindful that the life
of a veteran is always always
multi-dimensional it is rooted in the
pride and promise of Liberation coupled
with the everpresent possibility of
peril or
alienation all of these things are held
in tension and contain a longing for a
certain kind of peace to revive our
weary
world as we honor our veterans and we
seek to grow closer to this deep peace
may we embody a peace born from wisdom
and understanding a peace nurtured with
compassion and mercy a Peace
strengthened by courage and
commitment and may we be blessed this
day and every day by the shimmering
light of our god of many names Our God
who creates sustains and Embraces all
life
amen I'm we're going to close in a
second so you can sit down I only have a
few notes before we we sign off um so
before we go I do want to take a moment
to wish very happy birthday to the
United States Marine Corps simpy we know
it's your birthday so
congratulations um I also want to make
sure that you know that there will be a
veteran Yale veterans association
military history at Yale tour right
after this a walking tour that can
accommodate about 25 people it'll be
leaving from the ca right behind
me and I actually want to thank the the
planning committee and our ceremony
participants so thank you very much for
all of that you
did and special thanks to Tom Duffy and
the Yale uh School of Music brass
Ensemble for sharing with music
inspiring energetic thank you very
much we're going to learn all some of us
are going to learn all the songs Okay um
so when today has passed and we return
to our very busy lives I hope that we
will continue to remember the people of
Yale who have Faithfully taken oath to
protect and serve we are a stronger more
diverse and more inclusive community
because of them and I want to thank you
for enjoying for joining us have a great
[Music]
[Applause]
day